[Music]
in celebration of the unlikely
adventurer who started jrr tolkien's
epic lord of the rings adventure
this is the bilbo baggin story explained
bilbo baggins was born in the shire in
the year 2890 of the third age
the only son of bungo baggins in
belladonna took
bilbo spent his early life in the hobbit
hole known as bagant
which would remain his family home after
the death of his parents
as a boy bilbo always wanted to know
more about the things that were
happening outside the shire
this unusual trait drew the attention of
the wizard gandalf
but as bilbo got older he seemed to lose
this quality
he lived alone and was pleased to enjoy
the same comforts as his fellow hobbits
food drink and leisure and never causing
trouble for his neighbors
though bilbo didn't know it that was set
to change after he turned 50.
bilbo's early adulthood passed in quiet
comforted back end
but his calm life was disrupted by the
arrival of gandalf
who asked bilbo to take part in an
upcoming quest
soon strange dwarves began arriving on
bilbo's doorstep
13 in all the dwarves were led by thorin
oakenshield who explained to bilbo that
they were on their way
to erebor to reclaim their ancestral
home in the lonely mountain
the dragon smaug had forced the dwarves
out years earlier and now rested there
hoarding the treasure inside which is
why the dwarves needed bilbo's help
that's why we need a burglar good one
too
an expert i'd imagine and are you
bilbo was reluctant to go since he
didn't consider himself a burglar at all
but he ultimately agreed to set out from
the shire with the
on an dwarves after venturing out with
doran and company
bilbo encountered a trio of trolls who
nearly put an
end to the quest before gandalf came to
the rescue when the trolls turned to
stone
bilbo and the dwarves were able to raid
their nearby cave
it was here that bilbo discovered his
sword sting which he would keep for many
years
the company eventually reached the elven
city of rivendell
where bilbo met elrond for the first
time bilbo developed a fascination with
the elves
which he would carry with him for the
rest of his life the company left
rivendell to pass through the misty
mountains where they tried to shelter in
a cave
they soon found the goblins were
infesting the mountain and while bilbo
managed to escape
capture thorin and company were not so
lucky while the dwarves and gandalf
dealt with the goblins bilbo stumbled
through the dark and happened to find a
golden ring
soon after he encountered a strange
creature known as gollum
who threatened to eat him unless he
could win a riddle contest
bilbo stumped gollum with his final
riddle
what have i got in my pocket
as gollum grew more frustrated bilbo put
the ring on and vanished
gollum thought the hobbit had found a
way out and gave chase toward the cave
exit
bilbo used his newfound invisibility to
follow gollum making his way out of the
cave
outside bilbo reunited with the dwarves
who'd managed to fight their way out of
the misty mountains
the group was then attacked by wargs
only to be rescued by gandalf's friends
the great eagles
when the company finally arrived at the
lonely mountain bilbo snuck in through
the secret door on thorin's map
bilbo's entrance woke the dragon smaug
so bilbo put on the ring to stay hidden
and kept smaug busy with riddles until
he discovered the dragon had a bare
patch in his armor
bilbo told the dwarves of smaug's
weakness and a nearby thrush heard and
told
bard the bowman of nearby laketown when
smaug flew into a rage
and departed the mountain to burn the
town in retribution for bilbo's thievery
bard shot the dragon in the bare spot
killing him
but the struggle with the dragon was
only the beginning of the battle
groups of men and elves soon arrived to
lay claim to the mountain's treasure
the dwarves sent word to their own kind
for help
and just as a battle was about to ensue
bilbo revealed that he'd stolen the
arkanstone
the dwarf's most prized artifact from
the mountain
bilbo used it to try to broker peace but
soon
all three factions were interrupted by a
goblin army in the ensuing battle
known as the battle of five armies due
to the eagle's eventual participation
thorin was killed putting an end to his
quest to reclaim his kingdom
bilbo was supposed to receive 1 14th of
the lonely mountain's treasure but
instead
settled for two chests of gold and
silver he returned home to the shire
and when he arrived at bag end he
discovered that there was another battle
to fight
you're not supposed to be here what do
you mean
on account of you being presumed dead
enough
i am not dead presumed
is jealous and meddling cousins the
sackville baggins
had begun to auction off all of his
belongings so they could move into
baghdad themselves
only after buying back every piece of
his own furniture himself could bilbo
settle back into a normal life
he eventually began a book recounting
his adventures titled
there and back again but bilbo would
never be the same again
his long journey and surprising return
had led to rumors and whispers about
what he'd done
and what he was up to all alone in bag
end more importantly though he didn't
know it at the time
the ring he'd discovered in the misty
mountains had begun to take hold of him
as a result bilbo hardly seemed to age
at all for the next 60 years
as bilbo's 111th birthday celebration
approached
bilbo decided to head off on one final
adventure before his death
i want to see mountains again mountains
gandalf
bilbo's birthday party was massive and
bilbo ended it by putting on the ring
and disappearing
after the party bilbo prepared to set
out for rivendell
but gandalf confronted him about the
rings aware of the effect it was having
on his old friend
the wizard urged bilbo to leave the ring
along with bag end to his nephew frodo
bilbo was initially resistant but after
he calmed down he realized the wisdom of
gandalf's advice
bilbo gave the ring up and left the
shire unbeknownst to bilbo
gandalf's research would soon confirm
that the ring was in fact
the one ring forged by the dark lord
sauron
in a bid to control all of middle earth
by letting it go
and leaving it to frodo bilbo became the
first individual in the ring's history
to relinquish it voluntarily
bilbo stayed in the realm of elrond for
some time then left again to visit the
city of dale and gaze upon the lonely
mountain one more time
before returning again to rivendell
there he continued to work on his book
and began to notice that age was
catching up to him without the ring
he grew weaker and more feeble
eventually frodo arrived in rivendell
with the ring on a quest to destroy it
bilbo
still harbored a desire for the ring but
knew it was best if frodo succeeded in
his quest
bilbo gifted his nephew with two
remaining artifacts from his adventures
his sword sting and a mithril shirt
while bilbo remained in rivendell frodo
kept pushing toward mordor
eventually frodo succeeded in destroying
the ring
ushering in the fourth age the fourth
age came to be known as the age of men
since the great elven leaders left the
continent to sail west to the undying
lands
because they had been ring bearers frodo
and bilbo were invited to accompany
elrond
and the lady galadriel of lothlorien
across the sea
before departing middle earth bilbo
turned 131
making him the oldest hobbit in the
continent's history
he sailed west and presumably passed
away
in the undying lands at peace check out
one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about the
lord of the rings are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one